we have to start with the relationship between
England and France which is
not very good at the moment and
the
diplomatic and miserable situation in fact
if you are president what are
you going to do to fix it to change
that you know  at the same time we have had
worse between the French and the English
since we have spent centuries
waging war on each other so well we always have to put things into
perspective but joking
aside I think that if you want
the French Emmanuel Macron and
technocracy  Brussels we are making a
fundamental error, an error
of approach, that is to say that he considers
that England's departure from the famous
brexit
is a mistake and that the English
must pay for it and that France
and the Europeans must make them
pay for two reasons on the one hand
because they are relentless Europeanists and
that he considers that this choice
of England of the English people and not
only a mistake but a betrayal
of Europeanist ideals  and moreover
they want to dissuade the other countries
which would be tempted I don't know me
Hungary you see other countries like
that or even France
which would be tempted to leave the
European Union and dislocate their ideal I
think this this approach
ideological and moralizing it's not
good we're going to punish you like a child
is not appropriate to the situation
first of all because it's counterproductive
and the English are rightly rearing up
and therefore they too are showing
bad will we are going to see it for
for the history of fishing and moreover
because if you want I think that we
must respect the choice of the
English people yes that's quite simply it's
democratic it's respectful of the
English it's  respectful of what they
have chosen I find that even that the
English conservative elites in any
case a part of it is honored to have
respected the choice of the English people
unlike the French political elites
who you do not remember  come
maybe in 2005 when France had
said no to the referendum and to the treaty to
the European Constitutional Treaty no
no found nothing better than to have
this same European treaty voted by
parliamentarians that was unworthy I
find the behavior of the
English elites  much more noble on the
other hand what I wanted to say is
that obviously we must defend the
interests of French fishermen I find it
really cruel on the part of the English
to have like that suppress
the fishing rights
of French fishermen who are there
for years I was going to say for
centuries because some have had
licenses for a very long time I
don't think it works as they say in
England
here I find it unfair I find it
really
very harmful for these
French fishermen who don't have  I
find that Emmanuel Macron negotiated very badly
with the English I also find
that Michel Barnier the
chief negotiator of Brexit when  he was
European commissioner in Brussels
showed his limits there because it is
all the same incredible that
this subject is left in the air and that
this subject is not dealt with upstream during the
great negotiation of the Grand
post office bargaining  brexit there is of course this
fishing war but there is also
the migrants the migrants it's a good it's
a big story on the a small
channel and if you were
president would you stop in addition to that  the
French at the moment
the boats arriving in England
so I will tell you if I were
president and it would not have arrived in
Calais here I find it both
scandalous that we are
England's border guards
this agreement  du Touquet is neither made
nor frankly to receive money
from England to protect its
border finally I mean we are
not we are not a third world country
what so it is disrespectful for
France and I do not understand that the
governments  s French is accepted that's
good so I don't agree
with this agreement there but on the other hand on the other
hand
and where the English are right it is
that these people should never
arrive in Calais he should not
return to  France it shouldn't we
should do everything to dissuade them from
coming to France and
if you want more and more like
those who don't arrive in England
stay in France because obviously
they have social aid because
obviously they have  the hope of an
easy regularization because of a
circular issued by Manuel Valls a
few years ago so we pay him in
addition it's not only the English
you see that he pays it's us
who  let's pay it and in addition it makes
life unlivable in Calais
throughout the region because it
is spreading everywhere with the complicity
of smugglers and associations for the
defense of migrants who are accomplices
of the smugglers so I will punish the
smugglers  I p  I will unite the associations for the
defense of migrants I will restore
because it was suppressed under pressure
from Europe the crime of clandestinity and I will
expel these people and I will suppress
all social aid for these people
so that they no longer  are tempted to
come because it's good it's very
comfortable you understand we come from
very poor countries we come to France and
we receive sums that seem
marvelous to you compared to what you
had in your countries so obviously everything
the world is coming so we have to remove
all that we need better there I saw that
your Minister of the Interior had
said it he is absolutely he is absolutely
right France should
better control its border its
borders  with the other
European countries and also since Frontex is
in truth
useless Frontex these few
hundred agents who do not control anything and
moreover when the poor want to do
their job they turn back the migrants
they are accused  in the European Parliament
and by the Commission of Brussels of
brutality me I contract for example
in the Polish business I congratulate the
Polish government which is right
and it thinks that it should be helped and
contrary to the Commission of pixel
I think that  'everywhere it is
possible to build walls because
we can see it clearly with the images of
Belarus and Poland all these
migrants who come from the Middle East in
truth, immigration is war,
that's them  want to invade our
European countries that's all that's not that's
nothing else it's a war
do you think that preserving Macron he
uses immigrants as a wapuna
of war a weapon against England
like  the same thing no I don't think
no frankly I don't I do
n't pay him such malicious attention it
's not
Erdogan with us it's not no you
shouldn't exaggerate I just think
he is how to tell you
ideologically favored  ble
to immigration he thinks you know he has
an
individualist ideology he thinks that
basically every individual and it's the same and can
live anywhere so obviously
he's going to put rules here and there but
basically he's in favor of
this  frenzied individualism the
whole existence of peoples seems a little
outdated to him he thinks that peoples
don't exist that there are only
individuals who can live anywhere
and that's why and moreover he  doesn't dare
because they think it's harmful
he doesn't dare to face the the
dictates of judges today
whether they are French judges or European judges
who are the first
responsible with the emergence of  rights
of this migratory invasion we must
therefore confront this judicial power and
take away from migrants all these
automatic rights that the judges have
granted them to bring in countless
compatriots but that is the first
thing to do and do you think
that  is what  what english thing in origin
in fact
this spirit of Macron you call it
individualization individualism
do you think it's an
IDS of Regent Thatcher
I wouldn't say that it's an old
idea also it's a  it's a diversion
of Christian humanism it's as
startone said it's
Christian virtues gone crazy you see
it's nothing else it's simply
forgetting that in Christian humanism
there is indeed respect  of the
human being but which is rooted in a
culture a religion a people a land
there today that's why I say
these are Christian virtues gone
crazy we have an individual and a person
consecrates very well but that  we
completely isolate from his from his people from his
historical context from his mores you
see we believe that all individuals
are interchangeable they are
only consumers it's an
economist vision of the thing and that I
don't have I think  that  people are
first of all the product of their culture of
their people of their mores before
being consumers and we can see this in fact
it's the right he has that he has pushed
this for 20 years
the right of the right  political I
would not say that I would say that it is an
alliance between the effectively
purely economist discourse of a certain
right which called itself liberal and which
was globalist and another left
which also renounced the republican assimilation which
it defended
who once adopted more
Anglo-Saxon, more communitarian principles in the name
of an anti-racism there too misguided see
it is an alliance of a right
and a left and who has and it is above all
I will tell you  beyond that it
's cowardice, that is to say that our
rulers for 40 years are afraid
of confronting political correctness we
can riots in the suburbs are afraid
of being badly seen by the media are afraid
of  do not submit to the judge you
see it is above all the coward  been
and so you said before that if you
think now we're in a
third or maybe last phase
of this connection
between and
also islamism then you think
now you're approaching a
crisis that's right no  if you want what
I'm saying is that
there is an alliance
between
this individualism,
this sanctification of the rights of
the individual and Islam, which uses it to
impose its vision of the world first of all to
impose its  demography then his vision of the
world and then I say that there is
indeed the wok ideology which is
a hyper individualism a
hypersensitivity to the right of the individual
a
generalized offensive against
French and Western culture against the
heterosexual white man we see  although his
enemies that and those people want above
all to make the French and
all Westerners feel guilty to shame them for their
history so that the French and the
Westerners and the Americans of guerlas
so much  don't get drunk on guilt
self as a [ __ ] self destroy you
see be ready to give up their
culture their civilization just
to stop feeling guilty that
's WoW culture and that's it if you
want wok culture  promotes
the Islamization of our countries it's not
it's by destroying our
cultures our history that obviously
they make a clean sweep of all that and which
allow a culture and a history
and a foreign civilization to
come  replace okay and then your
hobo
the right word is that workism is
like a
horse that is too young how
Iran
then not in Iran what I am saying is
not exactly that I am making a
comparison with Iran because  that
I explain if you want that to
reverse the cat will say there was an
alliance between the islamists as
enigmas you remember and the
communists at the time which was very
powerful
so they are put in two an alliance
an old alliance
islamagotc  history but which even goes back
to the 1920s since at the time it was
Lenin who had even sealed this
alliance in the famous congress of Baku
between Islam and the communist so
it's an old story but in Iran
when the Islamists are  came to
power what did they do
they put all the communists in prison
and they shot them so I say to the
Islamo-leftists of today that they
will be the next victims
of Islam but  in the meantime the alliance of the
two will have destroyed France will have destroyed
the French people will have destroyed its
morals will have destroyed its civilization
that's what I'm saying okay so finally
I'll ask you a somewhat
personal question is that you  are very
interested in nations I think you
talk a lot very
nicely
about the land things like that and
do you think it
becomes about your Jewish origins and
the West or ours is it
because  you are you feel a
little  foreigners that you are so interested
in nationalism
i hope it's not at all it's not
an insult i don't feel like a foreigner
to the limit i could tell you i
'm some kind of romanized
gallo-roman barbarian
but I am
more comfortable with it than in the misery
the misery in which we
all lived in Algeria apart from a few
privileged ones it must be understood that
these countries were cesspools and
that France has civilized to
enriched etc good now so I do not  I do
n't feel like a stranger at all I'm
just saying that I the nations you
said the nations I actually I
find that the nations are
how to tell you the pinnacle of
civilization that is to say that this mixture
of both small  and small
and large see proximity and and
and and and scale
it is for me a fairly subtle balance
moreover there is democracy only
within nations there is no
cultural proximity that within nations I like
the difference between nations I like that the
English are very different from the
French just as they are very different
from the Germans
I think that if you want the great
drama of globalization it is that
previously there were, if you want,
nations that were very  different from
each other and within each
nation there was a great
cultural coherence of the French and the English
today with globalization and
with mass immigration we have
done the opposite, that is to say that there  there is
a global standardization by
the globalism ideology of globalizing
as you very rightly say in
English your word globalization is much
deeper and more relevant than our
word globalization that you are
absolutely right and moreover within, on the
other hand, where it  there is global standardization
within each nation there is
a distancing of of considered
citizens of these countries there is a
disintegration of these nations which  those
who divide into a community into a
diaspora who no longer have much to
do with each other who no longer have a
common culture I regret this double
evolution and I think that we have to
fight it we have to fight it by
defending on the one hand  the French genius
against
the standardizing phenomenon
of globalization that
is a first thing and two we must
also fight the the the the
elements which disintegrate French unity
and which it has transformed into a
whole of community and diaspora
which does not  have nothing in common anymore and who
and who clash one day
is it perhaps a moment
of optimism then with brexit and
commonweb hockeus as you said yesterday
evening that France now has an
opportunity to become the strongest in
Europe,
I don't know if we have an opportunity to
come to be the strongest force in Europe,
it's sure that we are the last
military force, that on the military level,
that's  economically secure we
have  We have a lot of work because we
are, on the contrary, downgraded compared
to Germany, which in truth
now leads Europe and the French and
Emmanuel Macron in particular
pretend to speak of a
Franco-German couple to make believe in an
equality which  no longer exists except in our
distant memories
[Music]